from the once masterful director who
just couldn't leave well enough alone
comes the special effects blockbuster
that transformed the entire film
industry into an assembly line for
special effects blockbusters and action
figures Star Wars the first one we are
not calling it a new hope right along
with some of film's most iconic
characters surrounded by films most
iconic props and designs and some of the
most iconic locations ever to the point
where every single person place or thing
on screen has at least a 1000 word
Wikipedia article about it did you know
that these guys are called jizz Whalers
whalers meet heroes like Princess Leia
the most interesting of the two human
females in the entire movie han Solo a
real Han Solo tie obi-wan a wise Jedi
Master who doesn't remember the joy that
saved his life several times don't seem
to remember ever owning a droid the
droids conscious beings with feelings
and free will who were bought and sold
as slaves do you think they'll melt us
down please don't deactivate me hashtag
droid lives matter guys and Luke
Skywalker a 1e space brat I was going to
Tashi station to pick up some power
converters hmm
kinda reminds me of someone it's all obi
wan's fault
there's nothing I can do about it right
now I hate them but they're gonna kill
her it's not fair
it just isn't fair wait so Hayden
Christensen's acting choices were
intentional whoa mind blown together
they'll go on one of the most epic space
journeys of all time that would have
been totally unnecessary if anyone had
email I have placed information vital to
the survival of the rebellion into the
memory systems of this r2 unit to take
on the evil empire with an army of
clumsy idiots
led by the most threatening villain of
all time Darth Vader until you hear his
original voice tear this ship apart
please like you telling those tapes
finding the passengers of this vessel I
want them alive
not so epic now are you bro return to a
time when technology forced George Lucas
to collaborate with other people as a
teams up with masters and sound design
score editing and practical visual
effects to deliver a near-perfect movie
that he's made progressively worse with
each special edition because if there's
one thing the original Star Wars wasn't
missing its poorly rendered out of place
CGI animals filling up every square inch
of the frame dude come on get out of the
way I can't even see the movie relive
all the parts your nostalgia goggles
keep you from admitting we're kind of
dumb like this guy in a bargain bin
werewolf mask the lightsaber battle
where two old geezers gently poke at
each other and the most over-the-top
Freudian finale of all time Luke is the
best bush pilot in the outer-rim
territories look at the size of that
thing should be able to penetrate the
outer defense didn't go in oh look at
that speed would be able to pull out in
time that's what she said yeah so
whether you're an old man who can't move
on from a 38 year old movie for children
or a contrarian kid who thinks he's
being edgy when he says the prequels
were better one thing is for sure
han shot first
starring Skywalker's in flight boom
beats by braid star forward genuine
class dog is my co-pilot Weiser Porkins
oh that's just mean and Oscar into trash
can
Satan blue milk and Nazis in space
Joseph Campbell's Star Wars as bad as we
all want - real lightsaber let's be
realistic we'd cut off our own hand in a
week the screen junkies you know and
love just got bigger and we saved our
biggest surprise for last hey screech
dougie that you didn't see us coming
that's right you can see us coming every
week man as we unbox toys and play with
them right here exclusively on screen
junkies plus whoa how do we score them
screen junkies plus starring over a
dozen new shows featuring your favorite
personalities live movie and TV fights
each and every week on its trailer
commentaries featuring bonus jokes and
behind the scenes info interactive
programming starring you the viewer
exclusive invitations to special events
and screen junkies meetups across the
country and our first original scripted
series interns of field oh and do we
mention that we got Jay and Silent Bob
because we totally did screen junkies
plus start your three-month free trial
now at screen junkies com do or do not
there is no try
I lick doorknobs you're a hairy wizard
you are a natural a natural disaster
you shall not wait what was the line